Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca
加拿大油砂开采产生了大量的碳排放，因此六家最大的公司联合起来，在通往净零排放的道路上大步迈进。他们投资于技术和创新，已将每桶原油的平均排放量削减了 22%。他们与政府合作创造和保护就业机会，并正在开发世界最大碳捕集与封存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在稳步推进，我们正通过多种途径取得进展。请访问 pathwaysalliance.ca 网站了解我们的实地计划。
Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. In early 1998, three Finnish tourists were sound asleep at the Cedar Lodge Hotel near California's Yosemite National Park. The trio consisted of two young girls and an older woman who was acting as their guardian. At around 2am, they woke to the sound of something rattling. It wasn't particularly loud, but the hotel's remote setting, surrounded by acres of woodland,
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。关于机密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上的本集节目简介或访问我们的网站。1998 年初，三名芬兰游客在加利福尼亚州约塞米蒂国家公园附近的雪松旅馆（Cedar Lodge）内熟睡。这三人包括两名年轻女孩和一名担任她们监护人的年长女性。大约凌晨 2 点，她们被一阵嘎吱嘎吱的摇晃声惊醒。声音虽然不算特别大，但由于旅馆地处偏远，四周环绕着数英亩的林地，
meant that even quiet noises could cut through the silence like a buzzsaw. Like all of the rooms at the Cedar Lodge, the women's room opened to an outdoor parking lot that any passerby could pull into. They quickly realised that the rattling was coming from the front door of their room, just a few feet away. Someone was fiddling with the handle from the outside, trying to get in. The women had locked the door earlier, but this wasn't deterring the person on the other side. It sounded as though they were trying to gain access with a key, as opposed to using a tool or brute force. The older woman cried out in panic before calling the front desk. She informed hotel staff that someone was breaking into their room, but by this point, the rattling had stopped.
这意味着即使是轻微的噪声也能像电锯一样刺破寂静。和雪松旅馆的所有房间一样，这几位女士的房间也通向一个室外停车场，任何路人都可以把车开进来。她们很快意识到，这嘎吱声正是从几英尺外她们房间的正面大门传来的。有人正在外面摆弄门把手，试图闯进来。这些女士之前已经锁上了门，但这并没有吓退门外的人。听起来对方好像是用钥匙而不是工具或蛮力试图进入。那位年长的女士惊慌失措地大叫起来，随后拨打了前台电话。她通知旅馆工作人员说有人正试图闯入她们的房间，但就在这时，摇晃声已经停了。
If someone had indeed tried to break in, they were gone by the time security was notified. No one was found loitering in the area, nor seen sprinting away. The hotel's maintenance man checked the door. The lock appeared untouched and was still fully functional, which put the women at ease. Their night continued without any further interruptions, and no other suspected break-ins were reported. In December 1998, Sylvina Paloso left her home city of Córdoba, Argentina, bound for the United States. The 16-year-old had inherited her mother's spirit for travel, and had signed up to be a foreign exchange student. For the next three months, Sylvina would be living with the six-member Sunda family in the northern Californian port city of Eureka.
如果确实有人试图闯入，那么在保安接到通知赶到时，他们已经不见了。没有人在附近游荡，也没有人被看到飞奔离开。旅馆的维修工检查了这扇门。锁看起来完好无损，且功能依然正常，这让这几位女士安心了下来。当晚余下的时间没有再发生任何插曲，也没有报告其他可疑的入室盗窃事件。1998 年 12 月，西尔维娜·帕洛索（Sylvina Paloso）离开她的家乡阿根廷科尔多瓦，前往美国。这位 16 岁的女孩继承了母亲热爱旅行的精神，报名成为了一名交换生。在接下来的三个月里，西尔维娜将寄宿在北加州港口城市尤里卡（Eureka）的桑达（Sunda）一家六口家中。
The Palosos and Sons were longtime friends through mothers Raquel and Carol. The two women met in the 70s, when Carol traveled to Argentina as an exchange student herself. Carol revisited the country years later with her two-year-old daughter, Juliana, better known as Julie. By this stage, the Palosos had two daughters, with Sylvina the younger of the pair. She and Julie Sunda were similar in age, but opposites in personality. Sylvina was an introvert, unlike Julie, who was more outgoing. Despite their differences, the girls formed a lifelong friendship of their own. Sylvina was due to return home from the US in late March 1999.
帕洛索家族和桑达家族是通过各自的母亲拉奎尔（Raquel）和卡罗尔（Carol）结下的多年交情。这两位女性相识于 20 世纪 70 年代，当时卡罗尔作为交换生前往阿根廷。多年后，卡罗尔带着她两岁的女儿朱莉安娜（Juliana，更常被称为朱莉）再次访问了该国。此时，帕洛索家已经有了两个女儿，西尔维娜是其中较小的一个。她和朱莉·桑达年龄相仿，但性格截然相反。与比较外向的朱莉不同，西尔维娜性格内向。尽管存在差异，两个女孩还是结下了属于她们自己的终身友谊。西尔维娜原定于 1999 年 3 月下旬从美国返回家乡。
As she was very interested in American culture, the Sons had endeavored to give her a memorable experience of their homeland. They had taken Sylvina all across the state to visit landmarks such as Disneyland and Fisherman's Wharf. The Grand Canyon in Arizona was next on their list, as was Yosemite National Park. It took Carol Sunda a month to meticulously plan the perfect road trip to Yosemite. Carol's schedule was typically full with family, work and other commitments, so she made the most out of every minute of her vacations. The Yosemite trip revolved around one of Julie's cheerleading competitions and would be taking place over four days that encompassed a long weekend. Only Carol, Julie and Sylvina would be going. It was set to be a unique adventure, as winter had brought snow to the region.
由于她对美国文化非常感兴趣，桑达一家一直致力于给她提供一次难忘的家乡体验。他们带着西尔维娜走遍了全州，参观了迪士尼乐园和渔人码头等标志性景点。亚利桑那州的科罗拉多大峡谷和约塞米蒂国家公园都在他们的下一站名单上。卡罗尔·桑达花了一个月的时间精心策划了这趟完美的约塞米蒂自驾游。卡罗尔的日程通常排满了家庭、工作和其他事务，因此她充分利用了假期的每一分钟。这次约塞米蒂之行围绕着朱莉的一场啦啦队比赛展开，将在一个包含长周末的四天内进行。只有卡罗尔、朱莉和西尔维娜三人同行。由于冬季给该地区带来了降雪，这将是一场独特的探险。
The trip began on Friday, February 12. Carol, Julie and Sylvina flew to San Francisco. From there, they hired a car and drove two hours northeast to Stockton. The city was home to the University of the Pacific, where Julie's cheerleading competition took place on Saturday, February 13. Julie was impressed by the campus and considered enrolling there after graduating high school. She had ambitions to become either a chef or an architect while maintaining her passion for violin and piano. Julie, Carol and Sylvina organized to return to the University for a proper tour in three days' time. From Stockton, the trio drove to the small farming town of Merced, known as the Gateway to Yosemite.
行程于 2 月 12 日星期五开始。卡罗尔、朱莉和西尔维娜飞往旧金山。从那里，她们租了一辆车，向东北驱车两小时来到斯托克顿（Stockton）。这座城市是太平洋大学的所在地，朱莉的啦啦队比赛于 2 月 13 日星期六在那里举行。朱莉对校园印象深刻，并考虑在高中毕业后去那里就读。她既有成为厨师或建筑师的抱负，同时也保持着对小提琴和钢琴的热情。朱莉、卡罗尔和西尔维娜计划在三天后返回该大学进行一次正式的参观。从斯托克顿出发，三人驱车前往被称为约塞米蒂门户的小型农业小镇默塞德（Merced）。
They spent the night at the Ramada Inn before continuing on to Yosemite National Park on the Sunday. Sylvina was particularly excited to see Yosemite's granite cliffs, waterfalls, lakes, meadows and mountains. She was an active person by nature, who enjoyed ice skating, skiing and roller skating. She also loved the outdoors and hoped to study an environmental field in the future. Carol, Julie and Sylvina spent their first day at Yosemite exploring part of the park's 750,000 acres of rugged wilderness. Before day's end, they drove through the dense and far-reaching forests along Highway 140 to the nearby town of El Portal. There, they checked in at the Cedar Lodge, an affordable hotel on the banks of the Merced River. On the evening of Monday, February 15, Yen's son received a phone call from his wife, Carol.
她们在华美达酒店（Ramada Inn）过夜，然后于周日继续前往约塞米蒂国家公园。西尔维娜对约塞米蒂的花岗岩悬崖、瀑布、湖泊、草地和山脉感到格外兴奋。她天性好动，喜欢滑冰、滑雪和轮滑。她也热爱大自然，并希望将来学习环境科学领域。卡罗尔、朱莉和西尔维娜在约塞米蒂度过了她们的第一天，探索了该公园占地 75 万英亩的崎岖荒野的一部分。天黑之前，她们沿着 140 号公路穿过浓密而绵延的森林，来到了附近的埃尔波塔尔（El Portal）小镇。在那里，她们入住了一家位于默塞德河畔的经济型酒店——雪松旅馆。2 月 15 日星期一晚上，延斯（Yen's）的儿子接到了他妻子卡罗尔的电话。
She happily spoke of her time away with the Julie and Sylvina in Yosemite. They had spent the previous two days exploring the park and were settling in for their final night at the hotel. Yen's planned to meet the three women at San Francisco International Airport the next day. Carol and Julie would return home to Eureka, while Sylvina would join Yen's and the other three Sunday children on a flight to Phoenix, Arizona to visit the Grand Canyon. Yen's and his children flew in to San Francisco at 10.45pm on Tuesday, February 16. A storm had delayed their flight by five hours. There was no way to notify Carol as she didn't have a mobile phone. Instead, Yen's paged his wife over the airport's loudspeaker, but there was no sign of her, Julie or Sylvina.
她开心地谈起她和朱莉以及西尔维娜在约塞米蒂度假的时光。她们在过去的两天里探索了公园，并在酒店安顿下来准备度过最后的一晚。延斯计划第二天在旧金山国际机场与这三位女士会合。卡罗尔和朱莉将返回尤里卡的家，而西尔维娜则将与延斯以及其他三个桑达家的孩子一起乘坐飞往亚利桑那州凤凰城的航班去参观大峡谷。延斯和他的孩子们于 2 月 16 日星期二晚上 10 点 45 分飞抵旧金山。一场暴风雨导致他们的航班延误了五个小时。由于卡罗尔没有手机，因此无法通知她。相反，延斯通过机场的扩音器呼叫他的妻子，但没有看到她、朱莉或西尔维娜的踪影。
The connecting flight to Phoenix was departing immediately. Yen's faced a snap decision, bored without Sylvina, or wait and missed the flight. He decided to leave without her. His wife was very resourceful and fully capable of booking Sylvina on another flight. Yen's awoke in Arizona the next morning and played a round of golf. He wasn't concerned about Carol, Julie or Sylvina until midday came and he still hadn't heard from them. Worried that they might have been in a car accident, he contacted the California Highway Patrol, but no incidents had been reported. Yen's then called the Cedar Lodge in El Portal.
飞往凤凰城的转机航班即将起飞。延斯面临着一个突如其来的决定：没有西尔维娜就独自登机，还是等待并错过航班。他决定不等她直接离开。他的妻子非常机智，完全有能力帮西尔维娜改签另一趟航班。第二天早上，延斯在亚利桑那州醒来并打了一场高尔夫球。直到中午过去依然没有她们的消息，他才开始担心起卡罗尔、朱莉和西尔维娜。担心她们可能遭遇了车祸，他联系了加利福尼亚州公路巡警局，但没有报告任何事故。随后，延斯致电位于埃尔波塔尔的雪松旅馆。
He was informed that his wife and the girls had seemingly left the day before as planned. The Lodge had Carol's credit card details on file, which meant she didn't need to physically check out at the front desk. She simply left the hotel keys in her room and her card was charged accordingly. Yen's contacted the rental car company that Carol had used. She was supposed to drop the vehicle off in Modesto before her flight to San Francisco. The car hadn't yet been returned. It was out of character for Carol not to follow through with plans. The 42-year-old was diligent and reliable.
他被告知，他的妻子和女孩们似乎已按计划于前一天离开。旅馆存有卡罗尔的信用卡信息，这意味着她不需要在前台进行物理退房。她只需将酒店钥匙留在房间里，系统就会相应地扣除她卡上的费用。延斯联系了卡罗尔使用的租车公司。她本应在飞往旧金山之前在莫德斯托（Modesto）还车。但这辆车尚未归还。卡罗尔不履行计划并不是她的性格。这位 42 岁的女性做事勤勉、可靠。
As a mother of four and co-owner of a real estate company, she had to be. Carol also worked in the local courts as an advocate for abused children, volunteered as a parenting teacher, and pursued other business interests. She was known for her charity work, including a nonprofit she co-founded that provided care and shelter for the mentally disabled. The Suns notified the Sheriff's Department in Yosemite of the trio's disappearance. It was initially thought that Carol and the teens were lost or had skidded off the road. A large-scale multi-agency search commenced. Police officers and park rangers were on the lookout for Carol's rental car, a bright red 1998 Pontiac Grand Prix with Californian license plates.
作为四个孩子的母亲和一家房地产公司的联合老板，她不得不如此。卡罗尔还在当地法院担任受虐儿童的倡导者，志愿担任家长培训老师，并追求其他商业利益。她以慈善工作而闻名，包括她共同创立的一个为智障人士提供照料和庇护的非营利组织。桑达一家向约塞米蒂的警长部门通报了三人的失踪情况。最初人们认为卡罗尔和这几位青少年迷路了或者车子滑出了公路。一场大规模的多机构搜救行动随即展开。警察和公园管理员一直在搜寻卡罗尔的租车，那是一辆挂着加州车牌的亮红色 1998 年庞蒂亚克大奖赛（Pontiac Grand Prix）轿车。
Highway Patrol drove down Highway 120, which runs through Yosemite, as well as Highway 140, which connects the Cedar Lodge with the park. There was no evidence of a vehicular accident or mishap anywhere. Records from the Cedar Lodge confirmed the women had checked in on the afternoon of Sunday, February 14. The lodge was at capacity due to it being both Valentine's Day and the President's Day long weekend. They were assigned to Room 509, a twin bedroom away from the central reception area and car park. By Monday afternoon, most of the hotel guests had checked out. Carol, Julie and Sylvina were the only ones remaining in their block. They rented some movies from the front desk and that evening, Julie and Sylvina ate at the hotel's restaurant.
公路巡警驱车沿着穿过约塞米蒂的 120 号公路以及连接雪松旅馆和公园的 140 号公路行驶。各处均没有发生车祸或事故的迹象。雪松旅馆的记录证实，这些女士于 2 月 14 日星期日下午入住。由于正值情人节和总统日长周末，旅馆客满。她们被分配到 509 房，这是一间远离中央接待区和停车场的双床房。到了周一下午，大部分酒店客人已经退房。卡罗尔、朱莉和西尔维娜是她们那一栋仅存的人。她们从前台租了一些电影，那天晚上，朱莉和西尔维娜在酒店的餐厅吃了饭。
The pair were halfway through their dinner when Carol arrived to pay the bill at 6.32pm. Julie and Sylvina left with Carol, telling their server they would be back to finish their half-eaten burgers. But they never returned. Room 509 hadn't been touched since Carol and the teens had left. Police searched the room and found the rented movies on a table along with a paper bag containing souvenirs. There were also wet towels on the bathroom floor and an apple and a bottle of tomato juice in the fridge. The group's luggage was gone and their room key had been left behind as per the hotel's checkout policy. Police contacted the University of the Pacific in Stockton.
两人吃到一半时，卡罗尔在下午 6 点 32 分赶来结账。朱莉和西尔维娜和卡罗尔一起离开了，她们告诉服务员会回来吃完剩下的一半汉堡。但她们再也没有回来。自从卡罗尔和几位青少年离开后，509 房就再也没有人动过。警方搜查了房间，在桌上找到了租来的电影，以及一个装有纪念品的纸袋。浴室地板上还有湿毛巾，冰箱里有一个苹果和一瓶番茄汁。这群人的行李不见了，按照酒店的退房政策，她们的房间钥匙被留在了房里。警方联系了斯托克顿的太平洋大学。
The trio had scheduled to tour the campus hours before their flight back to San Francisco on the 16th, but they didn't show up. Their absence wasn't reported as it was assumed they had simply made other plans. 30 miles southeast of Stockton is the inland city of Modesto, the final destination on Carol, Julie and Sylvina's road trip. On Friday, February 19, a teen was walking to school in Modesto's northern suburbs. Near the intersection of main thoroughfares Briggsmore Avenue and Tully Road, she spotted the insert of a wallet containing several cards. Inside were Carol's son's driver's license and credit cards, confirming it belonged to her. It was unclear whether the wallet insert had been lost, abandoned or stolen. That same day, a call came through to the Wells Fargo bank helpline from someone claiming to be Carol's son.
这三人原定于 16 日飞回旧金山之前的几个小时参观校园，但她们并没有出现。由于人们以为她们只是另有安排，因此她们的缺席并未被上报。莫德斯托是卡罗尔、朱莉和西尔维娜自驾游的最后一站，位于斯托克顿东南 30 英里处的一个内陆城市。2 月 19 日星期五，一名十几岁的女孩正走在莫德斯托北部郊区的上学路上。在主干道布里格斯莫尔大道（Briggsmore Avenue）和塔利路（Tully Road）的交叉口附近，她发现了一个夹着几张卡片的钱包内页。里面有卡罗尔儿子的驾照和信用卡，确认这个钱包属于她。目前尚不清楚这个钱包内页是丢失、遗弃还是被盗。当天，韦尔斯法戈银行（Wells Fargo）的求助热线接到一个电话，对方自称是卡罗尔的儿子。
This person requested a duplicate ATM card be sent to her, but she was unable to provide proof of identity, so the call was terminated. Two days later, the person claiming to be Carol called the helpline again, wanting to know her bank balance. This time she provided Carol's social security number and was given the information. When investigators learnt of the wallet insert and to the helpline calls, they suspected Carol had met with foul play. It seemed likely that the caller seeking her ATM card and banking details was an imposter. Wells Fargo provided details of the 800,000 calls made to their helpline between February 19 and 21. Investigators whittled down the list and looked into over 100 people who might have placed the call, but their efforts were unsuccessful. Bank records revealed that Carol's last purchase were the burgers Julie and Sylvina ordered at the Cedar Lodge restaurant the evening before they vanished.
此人要求将一张补办的 ATM 卡寄给她，但由于她无法提供身份证明，通话被终止。两天后，自称卡罗尔的人再次拨打求助热线，想要查询她的银行余额。这一次她提供了卡罗尔的社会安全号码，并获悉了相关信息。当调查人员得知钱包内页和求助热线电话后，他们怀疑卡罗尔遭遇了不测。索取她的 ATM 卡和银行资料的来电者似乎是一个冒名顶替者。韦尔斯法戈银行提供了 2 月 19 日至 21 日期间拨打其求助热线的 80 万个电话的详细信息。调查人员缩小了名单范围，调查了 100 多名可能拨打过该电话的人，但努力均告失败。银行记录显示，卡罗尔的最后一笔消费是朱莉和西尔维娜在她们失踪前一天晚上在雪松旅馆餐厅订购的汉堡。
She had also withdrawn $200 from an ATM in Merced before the group arrived at Yosemite. The cash was missing, but her credit cards hadn't been used, despite some having a $13,000 limit. The families of Carol, Julie and Sylvina descended on Yosemite, seeking answers. Six days into the search, a visibly stunned Yen's son confronted a press conference. The National Park was a meaningful place for Yens, as it was where he and Carol had honeymooned. He could often no reason why his family would be targeted in a crime. He described his wife and daughter as fighters who wouldn't easily succumb to an assailant. The Eureka community was equally shocked. They couldn't understand how someone as cautious and protective as Carol could end up in trouble.
在抵达约塞米蒂之前，她还从默塞德的一台自动取款机上取了 200 美元。这笔现金不见了，但尽管有些信用卡的额度高达 1.3 万美元，她的信用卡却一直没有被使用过。卡罗尔、朱莉和西尔维娜的家人来到约塞米蒂寻求答案。搜寻工作进行到第六天，神情明显震惊的延斯·桑达出席了一场新闻发布会。对延斯来说，这个国家公园有着特殊的意义，因为这里是他和卡罗尔度蜜月的地方。他根本想不出为什么他的家人会成为犯罪分子的目标。他将妻子和女儿描述为不会轻易向袭击者屈服的斗士。尤里卡社区同样震惊不已。他们无法理解像卡罗尔那样谨慎和有保护意识的人怎么会陷入麻烦。
Carol had come from the wealthy Carrington family. Her parents lived on a sprawling ranch north of Eureka, partially funded by their successful real estate business that Carol inherited. She and Yen's ran the business side by side. The couple were also principals in the Carrington Co, which owned several malls across the country. Yet, the sons didn't indulge a lavish lifestyle. They lived in a modest pale green bungalow with their two pet dogs. If the perpetrators were targeting the Carrington's wealth, they had yet to make any ransom demands. Carol's parents put their money to use, offering a $250,000 reward for information. No questions asked. The family also chartered a plane to conduct an aerial search of Yosemite, but nothing of significance was spotted.
卡罗尔出身于富裕的卡林顿（Carrington）家族。她的父母住在尤里卡以北的一座大型牧场里，部分资金来自于他们成功的房地产业务，而卡罗尔继承了这份产业。她和延斯并肩经营这项业务。这对夫妇还是卡林顿公司（Carrington Co）的负责人，该公司在全国各地拥有多家购物中心。然而，桑达一家并没有过着奢侈的生活。他们和两只宠物狗住在一个简朴的淡绿色平房里。如果犯罪分子盯上了卡林顿家族的财富，他们当时还没有提出任何勒索要求。卡罗尔的父母将资金投入使用，悬赏 25 万美元征集线索。不问任何条件。该家族还包租了一架飞机对约塞米蒂进行空中搜寻，但没有发现任何有价值的线索。
By now, the FBI were involved in the case. Over two dozen agents had arrived at Yosemite, led by special agent James Maddock. They set up a command post at a nearby hotel. The walls of a conference room were plastered floor-to-ceiling with a timeline of events. It detailed all sightings of the missing women that had come through to a 24-hour case hotline. On the final day of their trip, the trio were allegedly spotted in Yosemite Valley, a 30-minute drive east from the Cedar Lodge. They reportedly asked for directions to Tuolumne Grove, a riverside meadow just over an hour's drive away. A sporty red vehicle was also seen parked in a Yosemite Valley lot between midday and 2pm that same day. The possibility that the trio had a car accident once again gained momentum and further searches of the parkland were carried out.
此时，联邦调查局（FBI）已介入此案。在特工詹姆斯·马多克（James Maddock）的率领下，两多打特工抵达了约塞米蒂。他们在附近的一家酒店建立了一个指挥所。会议室的墙壁从地板到天花板贴满了事件时间线。上面详细记录了通过 24 小时案情热线反馈的所有关于失踪女性的目击报告。在她们行程的最后一天，这三人据称在约塞米蒂山谷被目击，该山谷距离雪松旅馆向东车程 30 分钟。据报道，她们曾询问前往图奥勒米树林（Tuolumne Grove）的路，那是一片车程刚过一个多小时的河畔草地。当天中午到下午 2 点之间，人们还看到一辆运动型红色汽车停在约塞米蒂山谷的一个停车场里。这三人遭遇车祸的可能性再次受到关注，并对公园土地展开了进一步的搜寻。
Recent snowstorms hindered efforts, but within two days, 4,000 miles of roadway had been driven and 50 miles of terrain trudged on foot. As planes and helicopters scanned from above, what looked like the burned-out shell of a car was spotted along a back road. It turned out to be a propane tank. Special Agent Maddock told reporters, The territory here is huge, the territory is rugged, and the search is going to take some time. But if the car is out there, we'll find it. By Friday, February 26, Carol, Julie and Sylvina had been missing for 10 days. Nine abandoned or stolen cars had been found throughout Yosemite, but none were Carol's missing rental.
近期的暴风雪阻碍了搜救工作，但在两天内，搜救车辆行驶了 4000 英里的道路，步行跋涉了 50 英里的地形。当飞机和直升机在空中扫描时，一条小路旁发现了一个看起来像烧毁的汽车外壳的物体。结果证明那是一个丙烷罐。特工马多克对记者说：“这里的领土巨大，地势险峻，搜寻工作需要一些时间。但如果车子在那里，我们会找到它的。”截至 2 月 26 日星期五，卡罗尔、朱莉和西尔维娜已经失踪 10 天了。约塞米蒂各地发现了九辆被遗弃或被盗的汽车，但没有一辆是卡罗尔失踪的租车。
While the likelihood of a car accident no longer seemed to likely, it couldn't be ruled out entirely. Carol's car might have plunged into a remote canyon and remained hidden by shrubs or snow. Special Agent Maddock urged the public to check their properties and unused barns for the Red Pontiac, advising it may have been salvaged or dismantled. Carol's parents offered a further $50,000 reward for any information leading to the Pontiac's location. This was distinct from their reward for Carol, Julie and Sylvina's whereabouts, which they bolstered to $300,000. Alleged sightings continued to come in. A best Western hotel clerk in Oakland believed the three women had approached the desk inquiring about room rates. Another person reported seeing them at a roadside fruit stand in Escalon.
虽然发生车祸的可能性似乎不再那么大，但也不能完全排除。卡罗尔的车可能坠入了偏远的峡谷，被灌木丛或积雪掩盖而未被发现。特工马多克敦促公众检查他们的房产和未使用的谷仓，寻找这辆红色的庞蒂亚克轿车，并建议它可能已被变卖或拆解。卡罗尔的父母又悬赏 5 万美元，征集任何有助于找到这辆庞蒂亚克下落的线索。这与他们为寻找卡罗尔、朱莉和西尔维娜下落而提供的悬赏金不同，后者已被他们提高到 30 万美元。关于目击者的传闻仍在继续涌现。奥克兰的一名贝斯特韦斯特酒店（Best Western）职员认为这三名女性曾走近前台询问房价。另一个人报告说在埃斯卡隆（Escalon）的一个路边水果摊看到了她们。
Both locations were in close proximity to Modesto, but neither sighting was confirmed. Yens's son and others close to the missing women were subjected to polygraph testing and ruled out as suspects. Yens was struggling to remain positive and often broke down. He prepared himself for the worst, telling his other children that they'd been lucky so far, but their lives were about to get harder. Carol was Yens' high school sweetheart. The couple had created their perfect family, starting with the birth of Julie in 1983, followed by the adoption of three more children. Carol was described as a supermom, and Yens wasn't sure how they'd cope without her. The son's grief was shared by the Paloso family.
这两个地点都靠近莫德斯托，但目击事件均未得到证实。延斯·桑达和其他接近失踪女性的人接受了测谎测试，并被排除在嫌疑人之外。延斯一直在努力保持积极心态，并经常崩溃。他做好了最坏的打算，对他的其他孩子们说，他们到现在为止一直很幸运，但他们的生活将会变得更加艰难。卡罗尔是延斯的青梅竹马。这对夫妇创建了他们完美的家庭，始于 1983 年朱莉的出生，随后又收养了三个孩子。卡罗尔被形容为超级妈妈，延斯不知道没有她他们将如何应对。桑达一家的悲痛与帕洛索家族感同身受。
Sylvina's mother Raquel had arrived in California from Argentina. She was later joined by her husband, Sylvina's father, Jose. Raquel initially thought that her daughter had been in an accident. She told the press, The only thing I was afraid of was earthquakes in California. I trust the SUND family. I considered that they were going to take good care of my daughter, and I'm sure that they did. According to Raquel, Sylvina had never expressed concern about her time in America.
西尔维娜的母亲拉奎尔从阿根廷来到了加利福尼亚。她的丈夫、西尔维娜的父亲何塞（Jose）随后也加入了她的行列。拉奎尔最初以为她的女儿遇到了事故。她对记者说：“我唯一害怕的是加利福尼亚的地震。我相信桑达家族。我认为他们会照顾好我的女儿，而且我相信他们确实做到了。”据拉奎尔所说，西尔维娜从未对她在美国的时光表示过担忧。
It was her daughter's dream to go to the States. When Carol's son made the trip to Argentina in the 70s, it was during an intense time of political turmoil. Raquel said, I can't help but think if Carol could come to Argentina and survive that experience, the guerrilla fighting, the shootings. How could my daughter not come to America and survive here? I have hope. I believe someone has seen something. In this world, you can do few things without a witness. As the end of February neared, 50 FBI agents were working the case.
去美国是她女儿的梦想。当卡罗尔的儿子在 70 年代前往阿根廷时，正值政治动荡的紧张时期。拉奎尔说：“我禁不住想，如果卡罗尔能够来到阿根廷并在那段经历、游击战和枪击中生存下来，我的女儿怎么就不能来美国并在美国生存呢？我抱有希望。我相信有人看到了什么。在这个世界上，没有目击者你是很难做成几件事的。”随着 2 月底的临近，50 名 FBI 特工正在处理此案。
7000 miles of terrain had been covered, and 900 tips generating 233 leads had been followed up. But authorities had yet to find any concrete evidence that a crime had even occurred. Special agent Maddox stated that while the FBI held hopes of a miracle, they now believed that Carol and Julie SUND and Sylvina Paloso were no longer alive. By March, investigators were growing frustrated. It was unusual for them to work so hard on a case without making a single breakthrough. Television program America's Most Wanted did a feature on the disappearance. This garnered national attention for the case, but no further breakthroughs.
搜寻地形已覆盖 7000 英里，跟进了 900 条线索并从中产生了 233 条指引。但当局尚未找到任何确凿的证据来证明犯罪确实发生过。特工马多克表示，虽然 FBI 对奇迹抱有希望，但他们现在认为卡罗尔、朱莉·桑达和西尔维娜·帕洛索已经不在人世。到了 3 月，调查人员越来越感到沮丧。在一起案件中付出如此巨大的努力却没有取得任何突破，这让他们感到不寻常。电视节目《美国头号通缉犯》（America's Most Wanted）对这场失踪案进行了专题报道。这为该案赢得了全国关注，但没有取得进一步的突破。
Victimology, the study of victim behavior, was used to determine how the women might have reacted to various scenarios. Child abduction experts devised suspect profiles, and background checks were carried out on those who raised suspicion. Persons of interest were interviewed and polygraphed, but they were all eliminated from the investigation. That month, the FBI said about interviewing employees of the Cedar Lodge, and two suspects emerged. One was a staff member who had given Carol her room key. As it turned out, he was a registered sex offender. He had also visited Modesto two days before Carol's wallet insert was found there. The other suspect was a janitor named Billy Joe Strange.
受害人学（对受害人行为的研究）被用来确定这些女性可能对各种情况做出的反应。儿童绑架专家设计了嫌疑人侧写，并对那些引起怀疑的人进行了背景调查。相关利益人员接受了讯问和测谎，但他们最终都从调查中被排除了。当月，FBI 开始走访雪松旅馆的员工，并浮现出两名嫌疑人。其中一人是曾给卡罗尔房间钥匙的工作人员。事实证明，他是一名有案底的性犯罪者。在卡罗尔的钱包内页在那里被发现的两天前，他还曾访问过莫德斯托。另一个嫌疑人是一个名叫比利·乔·斯特兰奇（Billy Joe Strange）的门卫。
His history included domestic violence and battery. When investigators sought Strange for questioning in relation to the Sund Paloso case, he attempted to run. He was promptly captured and claimed that he'd fled because he didn't want to be hassled by the FBI. It was determined that Strange didn't have an alibi for the night the trio were last seen. He professed his innocence, but a polygraph test indicated that he wasn't being truthful. An associate claimed that Strange had talked about killing and raping women before hiding their bodies. Strange was interviewed several times, but there was no evidence linking him to the disappearance, and he was free to go. Locals who knew Strange were more inclined to believe that an outsider was responsible.
他的履历包括家庭暴力和殴打行为。当调查人员寻找斯特兰奇就桑达-帕洛索案进行讯问时，他试图逃跑。他很快被抓获，并声称他逃跑是因为他不想被 FBI 纠缠。经确定，斯特兰奇在三人最后一次被目击的那天晚上没有不在场证明。他坚称自己无罪，但测谎测试表明他在撒谎。一名同伙声称斯特兰奇曾谈论过强奸和杀害女性然后藏匿她们尸体的事。斯特兰奇被讯问了好几次，但没有证据将他与失踪案联系起来，他随后被释放了。认识斯特兰奇的当地人更倾向于认为是由外来人员造成的。
In contrast, Strange's former mother-in-law described him as a violent man with a strong temper. She was suspicious of him from the moment news of the Sund Paloso disappearance hit. Days later, investigators searched Billy Joe Strange's cabin in El Portel near the Cedar Lodge and found cannabis. This breached Strange's parole conditions, which forbade him from using illicit drugs. He was placed under arrest, and a search was carried out on his janitorial shed at the hotel. Inside, a waterlogged laundry bag was found that appeared to have a blood stain. Strange's girlfriend's car was also seized, and another blood-like stain was spotted on the carpet. Analysis of the substance concluded it was rust.
相比之下，斯特兰奇的前岳母形容他是一个脾气暴躁的暴力男子。自从桑达-帕洛索失踪的消息传出那一刻起，她就对产生了他怀疑。几天后，调查人员搜查了比利·乔·斯特兰奇位于雪松旅馆附近的埃尔波塔尔小屋，并发现了大麻。这违反了斯特兰奇禁止使用非法药物的假释条件。他被捕了，并且对其在酒店的门卫棚进行了搜查。里面发现了一个浸水且似乎有血迹的洗衣袋。斯特兰奇女友的汽车也被扣押，地毯上发现了另一个类似血迹的污渍。对该物质的分析断定那是铁锈。
As the one-month anniversary of Carol, Julie and Sylvina's disappearance approached, a vigil for hope was held in Modesto. It highlighted multiple missing-person cases, with many attendees carrying photos of loved ones whose whereabouts were unknown. Yen Sund didn't appear at the event, citing emotional exhaustion. A poem written by his 13-year-old daughter Regina was read out to the 600-strong crowd. It said, At a time when I need my mother's touch most, all I see of her are pitches nailed to a post. When it is time for bed, I rock myself to sleep. I try to stay strong because I know that's what you'd want your baby to be. But Mummy, I don't want you to leave me. On the afternoon of Thursday, March 18, retired carpenter Jim Powers was out target-shooting near Dodge Ridge Ski Resort.
随着卡罗尔、朱莉和西尔维娜失踪一个月的纪念日临近，莫德斯托举行了一场祈福守夜活动。活动聚焦了多起失踪人员案件，许多参加者带着亲人的照片，而这些亲人的下落至今不明。延斯·桑达没有出席活动，理由是情感极其疲惫。他 13 岁的女儿雷吉娜（Regina）写的一首诗被读给现场 600 名群众听。诗中写道：“在我最需要母亲抚摸的时候，我看到的全是钉在柱子上的寻人启事。到了该睡觉的时候，我摇晃着自己入睡。我努力坚强，因为我知道那是你希望你的宝贝成为的样子。但妈妈，我不想你离开我。”3 月 18 日星期四下午，退休木匠吉姆·鲍尔斯（Jim Powers）在道奇岭滑雪度假村（Dodge Ridge Ski Resort）附近进行打靶射击。
Located approximately 110 miles south of the Cedar Lodge, the area into Wallamy County is part of the Stanislaus National Forest. The forest spans almost 900,000 acres of woodland, rivers and streams. As Jim shuffled down a slope in some rugged terrain off Highway 180, something caught his eye. There were a few slivers of red paint and a license plate on the ground. Jim Powers eased the deeper into the dense forest and came across the wreckage of a burned-out car. The intense fire had stripped the paint off of all but one of the door handles. All that remained was the rusting metal shell with the interior soggy from recent rain. Jim examined at the license plate at Red 4BMV025.
该地区位于图奥勒米县，距离雪松旅馆约 110 英里，是斯坦尼斯劳斯国家森林（Stanislaus National Forest）的一部分。该森林拥有近 90 万英亩的林地、河流和小溪。当吉姆顺着 180 号公路旁崎岖地形的一个斜坡往下走时，有什么东西吸引了他的眼球。地上有几片红色的漆片和一个车牌。吉姆·鲍尔斯向茂密的森林深处走去，偶然发现了被烧毁的汽车残骸。猛烈的大火把除一个车门把手之外所有部件上的油漆都烧掉了。剩下的只有生锈的金属外壳，内部被最近的雨水浸湿。吉姆查看了车牌号：红底 4BMV025。
His adrenaline surged. He recognized it from the missing person-flyers that had been circulating the local community. With his stomach in knots, Jim took it back to his car and drove home to contact the authorities. FBI agents descended on the forest immediately. With the help of the Highway Patrol, they identified the destroyed vehicle as the Pontiac rented by Carol Sand. It had been missed during aerial searches due to the density of the forest ceiling above it. As a result of his discovery, Jim Powers was granted the $50,000 reward from Carol's parents. They called Jim their hero, as without the crucial find, the investigation would still be at a standstill. Jim said he would use the money to send his children to college.
他的肾上腺素飙升。他从在当地社区流传的失踪人员传单中认出了它。吉姆吓得心惊肉跳，他把它拿回车里，开车回家联系当局。FBI 特工立即涌入森林。在公路巡警的协助下，他们确认这辆被毁坏的车辆就是卡罗尔·桑达租用的庞蒂亚克轿车。由于上方森林树冠过于茂密，它在空中搜寻时被漏掉了。由于他的这一发现，吉姆·鲍尔斯获得了卡罗尔父母提供的 5 万美元悬赏。他们称吉姆为他们的英雄，因为如果没有这个关键发现，调查仍将陷入停滞。吉姆表示他会用这笔钱送他的孩子上大学。
Arson investigators confirmed that the Pontiac's interior had been doused with gasoline before being deliberately torched. The heat from the flames had been so extreme that tree branches 25 feet above were scorched. This would have likely caused the forest fire had the surrounding woods not been covered with ice and snow. Finding a burned-out item wasn't unusual for the area. It was known to be a dumping ground for old appliances and other junk which locals often set on fire. However, a local man who lived across the road from where the car was found had noted a peculiar odor two to three weeks earlier. It was the smell of something burning, but was different to fireplace smoke. A woman's hiking boot and an intact can of Coca-Cola were found near the burned-out car.
纵火调查人员证实，这辆庞蒂亚克的内部在被故意纵火前曾被浇过汽油。火焰产生的热量非常极端，以至于 25 英尺高的树枝都被烤焦了。如果周围的树林没有被冰雪覆盖，这很可能会引发森林大火。在该地区发现被烧毁的物品并不罕见。这里众所周知是废旧电器和其他垃圾的倾倒场，当地人经常放火焚烧它们。然而，住在车子被发现处马路对面的一名当地人在两到三周前曾注意到一种奇特的异味。那是某种东西燃烧的气味，但与壁炉的烟味不同。在烧毁的汽车附近发现了一只女式远足靴和一个完好无损的罐装可口可乐。
As darkness fell, a full forensic examination of the scene was postponed until morning. Special Agent James Maddock told reporters that although there were no bodies found in the car, they now had incontrovertible evidence that Carol, Julie and Sylvina had fallen victim to a violent crime. With her daughter and companions still missing, Raquel Paloso told the press, I just hope they are kept somewhere and alive. The following morning of Friday, March 19, the Pontiac's trunk was opened for the first time. Inside were the remains of two badly burnt bodies. It couldn't be ascertained whether they were male or female, but investigators were certain they had found either Carol, Julie or Sylvina.
随着夜幕降临，现场的全面法医勘验被推迟到早晨。特工詹姆斯·马多克对记者说，尽管车内没有发现尸体，但他们现在有了无可辩驳的证据，证明卡罗尔、朱莉和西尔维娜已经成为暴力犯罪的受害者。鉴于她的女儿和同伴依然失踪，拉奎尔·帕洛索对记者说：“我只希望她们被藏在某个地方而且还活着。”3 月 19 日星期五的第二天早晨，庞蒂亚克的后备箱第一次被打开。里面装着两具严重烧焦的尸体残骸。无法确定她们是男性还是女性，但调查人员确信他们已经找到了卡罗尔、朱莉或西尔维娜。
It would take time to compare the remains with DNA and dental records before they would know for sure. The damage to both bodies was so immense that a cause of death could not be established. Due to the wintery conditions, a perimeter search of the forest surrounding the Pontiac was difficult. Recent snowfall had also masked any footprints or other evidence that might have been left by those responsible. The bad weather led to a temporary suspension of the search. The son and Paloso families were in mutual shock. Carol's mother told the media, No one is strong enough to cope with something like this. I can't imagine what kind of monster would do something like this. Special Agent James Maddock expressed his hope that the third victim would be found alive.
将这些残骸与 DNA 和牙科记录进行对比需要时间，之后他们才能确定。两具尸体受损如此严重，以至于无法确定死因。由于冬季的天气状况，对庞蒂亚克周围森林的外围搜寻非常困难。最近的降雪也掩盖了可能是肇事者留下的任何脚印或其他证据。恶劣的天气导致搜寻工作暂停。桑达家族和帕洛索家族陷入了共同的震惊之中。卡罗尔的母亲对媒体说：“没有人坚强到足以应对这样的事情。我无法想象什么样的恶魔会做出这种事。”特工詹姆斯·马多克表达了他希望第三名受害者能被活着找到的愿望。
The FBI faced criticism in the aftermath of the discovery. The day after the women were last seen at the Cedar Lodge, they were allegedly spotted at a Tuolumne County gas station and at a gift shop. Both locations weren't far from where the Pontiac was found. These sightings were reported to the tip line, but were never followed up. The FBI defended this decision, with Special Agent Maddock stating that all the reported sightings they received couldn't logically be true. The Tuolumne County community consisted mostly of retirees and small business owners, but a number of methamphetamine labs were also known to operate in the area. The possibility that the crime was drug related was just one of many scenarios considered.
在这一发现之后，FBI 面临着批评。在这些女性最后一次在雪松旅馆被看到的第二天，据称有人在图奥勒米县的一个加油站和一个礼品店看到了她们。这两个地点距离发现庞蒂亚克的地方都不远。这些目击事件被报告给热线，但从未得到跟进。FBI 为这一决定进行了辩护，特工马多克表示，他们收到的所有报告的目击事件在逻辑上不可能都是真的。图奥勒米县的社区主要由退休人员和小型企业主组成，但也已知有一些冰毒实验室在该地区运营。该犯罪与毒品有关的可能性只是众多考虑的情况之一。
Special Agent Maddock thought the women had been carjacked. He believed multiple perpetrators were involved, as it would have been difficult for one individual to wrangle all three women. The perpetrators were likely local to the area, as the location where the vehicle was destroyed wasn't a place outsiders would be familiar with. Within 24 hours of the vehicle being recovered, approximately 300 calls were placed to the FBI tip line. Although the FBI would remain involved to some degree, the case was officially handed over to the Tuolumne County Sheriff's Department. On Sunday, March 21, a change in the weather allowed the search of the scorched forest to recommence. Not far from the dumping site, investigators came across several items of interest. The keys to the Pontiac, a handheld compact CD player, and an undamaged role of camera film.
特工马多克认为这些女性遭到了劫车。他认为有多名肇事者参与，因为单个人很难控制所有三名女性。肇事者很可能是当地人，因为销毁车辆的地点不是外地人会熟悉的地方。在车辆被找回后的 24 小时内，大约有 300 个电话打到了 FBI 的热线。尽管 FBI 在某种程度上仍将参与其中，但该案已正式移交给图奥勒米县警长办公室。3 月 21 日星期日，天气的好转使得对这片烧焦森林的搜寻得以重新开始。距离倾倒点不远处，调查人员发现了几个感兴趣的物品。庞蒂亚克的钥匙、一个手持式紧凑型 CD 播放器以及一卷完好无损的相机胶卷。
The film was developed, revealing images of Carol, Julie and Sylvina taken between February 13 and 15. The pictures depicted the trio's time in Yosemite, posing in front of spectacular landscapes, playing in the snow, and ice skating on a frozen lake. One photo was taken the night before the women disappeared, presumably by Julie. It captured Carol and Sylvina in their hotel room at Cedar Lodge, sitting on the edge of their beds. It was a candid shot, with Carol in the midst of rummaging through her handbag. Yet, both women were acknowledging the camera with a smile. Seven of the photos recovered from the camera roll were given to the Sun family, with Carol's mother telling the press. I didn't want to look at the photos at first.
胶卷冲洗出来后，显现出了卡罗尔、朱莉和西尔维娜在 2 月 13 日至 15 日之间拍摄的照片。这些照片描绘了三人呆在约塞米蒂的时光，她们在壮丽的风景前摆姿势，在雪地里玩耍，并在结冰的湖面上滑冰。其中一张照片是在女性失踪前一晚拍摄的，据推测是朱莉拍的。它捕捉到了卡罗尔和西尔维娜在雪松旅馆的房间里，坐在床边缘的画面。这是一张抓拍，卡罗尔正忙着在手提包里翻找东西。然而，两位女性都带着微笑面对着相机。从胶卷中恢复的七张照片被交给了桑达家族，卡罗尔的母亲对记者说：“我一开始不想看这些照片。
Once I saw them, I was really delighted. These are beautiful pictures of our girls, and to most likely, the last pictures we'll ever get. Jose Peloso sobbed when shown the images. The rest of the photographs were taken into evidence by the FBI, who refused to comment on what they showed. On March 21, a white cross and a vase of wildflowers were placed at the Pontiac dumping site by members of Carol, Julie and Sylvina's families. Carol's mother told the press, Carol was such a caring person. I just can't imagine the fear when she knew these girls were in trouble and couldn't do anything about it.
一旦我看到了它们，我真的感到很高兴。这些是我们女孩的美丽照片，而且很可能是我们能得到的最后照片了。”何塞·帕洛索在看到这些影像时泣不成声。其余的照片被 FBI 作为证据带走，他们拒绝就这些照片显示的内容发表评论。3 月 21 日，卡罗尔、朱莉和西尔维娜家属的成员在庞蒂亚克倾倒点放置了一个白色的十字架和一瓶野花。卡罗尔的母亲对记者说：“卡罗尔是一个非常关心他人的人。我只是无法想象当她知道这些女孩陷入困境却无能为力时的恐惧。”
The next day, dental records confirmed that one of the two bodies found in the vehicle belonged to Carol's son. Further DNA testing was required to verify the identity of the second victim. Two days later, on Wednesday, March 24, a letter arrived at the Modesto Police Department. Its envelope was postmarked March 16 and should have been delivered much earlier, but a mix-up at the post office delayed its arrival. Inside was a handwritten note in black ink on white lined paper. The writing was untidy and was accompanied by a crudely drawn map. It directed police to the Vista Point lookout at Dom Pedro Reservoir in Tuolumne County. A line was marked to represent Highway 120.
第二天，牙科记录证实车内发现的两具尸体之一属于卡罗尔·桑达。需要进一步的 DNA 测试来验证第二个受害者的身份。两天后的 3 月 24 日星期三，莫德斯托警察局收到了一封信。信封上的邮戳日期是 3 月 16 日，本应早得多送达，但邮局的混淆延误了它的到达。里面是一张用黑色墨水写在白色带线纸上的手写便条。字迹很潦草，并附有一张粗略绘制的地图。它指引警方前往图奥勒米县佩德罗湖水库（Dom Pedro Reservoir）的维斯塔波因特（Vista Point）瞭望台。划了一条线来代表 120 号公路。
Above the map were the words, we had fun with this one. Analysis of the note failed to uncover anything significant. DNA found on the stamp and the envelope's seal was run through the criminal database to no result. Investigators followed the map the next day, arriving at the Dom Pedro Reservoir on the western edge of Yosemite National Park. It was around halfway between where Carol, Julie and Sylvina were last seen and the location where their burned-out vehicle was found. Located just off Highway 120, Vista Point provided a scenic stop-off for visitors wanting to soak in the views of the expensive waterfront and its bordering tree-lined hillsides. It didn't contain much beyond a parking lot and a small hiking trail to the top of the hill. There were no direct access points to the water.
地图上方写着这样的话：“我们玩得很开心。”对字条的分析未能发现任何有价值的东西。在邮票和信封封口上发现的 DNA 被输入到犯罪数据库中，但没有结果。调查人员第二天按照地图前往位于约塞米蒂国家公园西缘的佩德罗湖水库。它大约位于卡罗尔、朱莉和西尔维娜最后一次被看到的地方与她们被烧毁车辆被发现的地点之间的大致半途。维斯塔波因特位于 120 号公路旁，为想要饱览宽阔水滨及其四周树木葱郁的山坡美景的游客提供了一个风景优美的停车站。除了停车场和一条通往山顶的小型远足小径外，那里没有太多其他东西。没有直接通往水域的通道。
A cadaver dog was taken down the steep, grassy hill that led to the reservoir. Within minutes, the canine made a discovery. Lying partly covered by a poison oak bush was the body of 15-year-old Julie Sund. Her throat had been cut, her ankles were duct-taped together, and her arms had been folded neatly across her chest. Upon the identification of both Carol and Julie Sund's remains, it was determined that the second body found in the Pontiac's trunk was that of 16-year-old Sylvina Paloso. Dark pink fibers were found on Julie's body. This prompted FBI agents to revisit the Cedar Lodge in search of Manchester that the fibers might have originated from. A maintenance worker took agents through each room where they stripped bedding and removed it from the premises to undergo analysis.
一头尸体搜寻犬被带下通往水库的陡峭草地斜坡。几分钟内，这只犬就有了发现。部分被毒橡树灌木丛覆盖着的，是15岁女孩朱莉·桑德的尸体。她的喉咙被割开，脚踝用强力胶带绑在一起，手臂整齐地交叉叠放在胸前。在确认了卡罗尔和朱莉·桑德的遗体身份后，经确定，庞蒂亚克汽车后备箱里发现的第二具尸体是16岁的西尔维娜·帕洛索。朱莉的尸体上发现了深粉色纤维。这促使联邦调查局特工重新造访雪松小屋，寻找纤维可能源自的曼彻斯特。一名维修工带着特工穿过每一个房间，他们在那里剥下床单并将其带离现场进行分析。
The triple homicide would come to be known as the Yosemite sightseer murders. Yen Sund had no mercy for those responsible and hoped they would face capital punishment. Quote, The senseless waste of these precious lives is so incomprehensible. I can't even begin to understand why it happened. Julie Sund was laid to rest in a private ceremony at her maternal grandparents' Californian ranch. Carol's body had yet to be released by the FBI, but a place was reserved for her to be buried alongside her daughter. The next day, a public memorial service was held at Eureka's Sacred Heart Church. Julie's violin and Carol's gardening hat were placed at the altar. Daisy's, Carol's favourite flower, were handed to the 1000-plus mourners in attendance.
这起三重谋杀案后来被称为约塞米蒂观光客谋杀案。延·桑德对肇事者没有丝毫怜悯，并希望他们面临死刑。他说：这些宝贵生命的无谓消逝是如此令人费解。我甚至无法开始理解为什么会发生这种事。朱莉·桑德在她外祖父母位于加利福尼亚的牧场举行的一场私人仪式中入土为安。卡罗尔的遗体尚未由联邦调查局释放，但现场已预留了一个位置，供她与女儿合葬。第二天，在尤里卡圣心教堂举行了一场公开追悼会。朱莉的小提琴和卡罗尔的园艺帽被摆放在祭坛上。黛西是卡罗尔最喜欢的花，被分发给出席的1000多名悼念者。
Reverend Thomas Keyes called upon the perpetrator of the crime to free the Sund family by coming forward so that the tragedy could be put to rest. Carol's family launched the Carol Sund Carrington Memorial Reward Foundation, which facilitated rewards for information to help families find missing loved ones. Before long, the Foundation experienced its first success story. The offer of a $10,000 reward led to the arrest of a suspect who shot and killed a young man named Robert Ibarra. The Foundation also offered a reward to help solve the murder of 18-year-old Brittany Phillips, as covered in episode 146 of Case File. The FBI released Carol and Sylvina's remains 37 days after they were discovered. Jose and Raquel Paloso had since returned home to Argentina to await the arrival of Sylvina's remains. Her body was transported to Raquel's hometown of Las Furetias.
托马斯·基斯牧师呼吁犯罪分子挺身而出，释放桑德一家，好让这场悲剧得以平息。卡罗尔的家属成立了卡罗尔·桑德·卡林顿纪念悬赏基金会，该基金会为提供线索帮助家庭寻找失踪亲人的行为提供悬赏。不久之后，该基金会迎来了它的第一个成功案例。1万美元的悬赏促成了一名枪杀并杀死了一名名叫罗伯特·伊巴拉的年轻人的嫌疑人的落网。该基金会还提供悬赏，以协助侦破18岁女孩布列塔尼·菲利普斯的谋杀案，这正如“档案”节目第146集所报道的那样。在卡罗尔和西尔维娜的遗体被发现37天后，联邦调查局将其释放。何塞和拉克尔·帕洛索夫妇此后已返回阿根廷家乡，等待西尔维娜遗体的运达。她的遗体被运送到拉克尔的家乡拉斯富雷蒂亚斯。
Residents lined the streets and threw roses at the hearth as it made its journey. Local factories and shops along the route were closed as a sign of respect. Over 1,000 mourners gathered for Sylvina's funeral. Her father said, We're at the end of a very painful story for us all. But finally, Sylvina is going to be able to rest in peace. Having Sylvina here is a huge relief. Yosemite National Park was federal property.
居民们排在街道两旁，当灵车驶过时向其抛撒玫瑰。沿途的本地工厂和商店为了表示敬意而关门停业。1,000多名哀悼者聚集在一起参加西尔维娜的葬礼。她的父亲说：对我们所有人来说，这是一段非常痛苦的故事的终点。但终于，西尔维娜将能够安息了。西尔维娜能回到这里是一个巨大的慰藉。约塞米蒂国家公园属于联邦财产。
Given that the murders were carried out there, a federal grand jury was pulled to assist authorities with the case. Although no arrests were imminent, this would give authorities more power to obtain documents and Sylvina reluctant or interstate witnesses. The criminal records of local men were poured over to identify suspects and those who had been convicted of violent crimes were spotlighted. One such person was Cedar Lodge janitor Billy Joe Strange, who was still in custody for violating his probation. 38-year-old car thief Terry Ray also caught investigators' attention. He was a known associate of persons of interest in the son Paloso case. On April 6, Terry's heavily decomposed body was found in the Tuolumne River. It appeared as though he had been in the water for up to three weeks.
鉴于谋杀案是在那里实施的，一个联邦大陪审团被组建起来以协助当局破案。尽管没有立即实施逮捕，但这将赋予当局更大的权力来获取文件以及西尔维娜那些不愿配合的或跨州证件的证人。当地男子的犯罪记录被仔细翻阅以识别嫌疑人，其中那些曾被判犯有暴力罪行的人成为了重点关注对象。其中一人是雪松小屋的门卫比利·乔·斯特兰奇，他因违反缓刑规定仍被拘留。38岁的汽车窃贼特里·雷也引起了调查人员的注意。他是索恩·帕洛索案中受关注人员的熟人。4月6日，特里的高度腐烂尸体在图奥米内河中被发现。看起来他在水中已经浸泡了长达三周之久。
Terry's brother, Dennis, was certain Terry had met with foul play. According to Dennis, Terry had been at a house in Modesto several weeks earlier where he witnessed a Julie's son to being assaulted. Dennis believed that his brother had been drugged and dumped in the river to stop him from speaking out about the crime. He said Terry was a strong swimmer who wouldn't have drowned accidentally. Yet, an autopsy failed to uncover any evidence that implicated anyone else in Terry Ray's death. Another man who made the suspect list in the son Paloso case was 42-year-old Michael Lawick. Lawick was a convicted rapist who had also served time for manslaughter, assault, drug possession, and attempted prison escape. In 1975, he brutally raped a relative while her children cowered in a nearby car.
特里的兄弟丹尼斯坚信特里遭遇了谋杀。据丹尼斯称，几周前特里曾去过莫德斯托的一处房子，在那里他目睹了一名朱莉·桑德的亲属遭到袭击。丹尼斯相信他的兄弟被下了药并被抛入河中，以阻止他说出这起罪行。他说特里是一名强壮的游泳健将，不可能意外溺水身亡。然而，尸检未能发现任何将其他人牵连进特里·雷之死的证据。索恩·帕洛索案中被列入嫌疑人名单的另一名男子是42岁的迈克尔·拉维克。拉维克是一名被定罪的强奸犯，他还曾因过失杀人、袭击、非法持有毒品和谋杀未遂越狱而服刑。1975年，他残酷强奸了一名亲属，当时她的孩子在附近的一辆车里瑟瑟发抖。
Two days prior to the discovery of the burnt-out Pontiac, Lawick was involved in a 14-hour standoff with police. He had been caught driving with expired license plates. During negotiations, Lawick fired a rifle at a police car and the standoff concluded with his arrest. Lawick's half-brother, 32-year-old Eugene Dykes, also raised suspicions. He too had a long criminal history that included unlawful sexual intercourse and false imprisonment. Dykes had been in custody since March 5 for parole violations, with his parole officer labelling him a danger to the community. Both Lawick and Dykes were known to hang around a group of methamphetamine addicts who supported their habit via mail theft and forgery. This raised the question of whether they'd been involved with the fraudulent calls to Wells Fargo to gain access to Carol's son's bank cards and accounts.
在被烧毁的庞蒂亚克汽车被发现两天前，拉维克曾与警方进行了长达14小时的对峙。他因驾驶过期车牌而被拦截。在谈判期间，拉维克向警车开了一枪，对峙以他的被捕告终。拉维克的同母异父兄弟、32岁的尤金·戴克斯也引起了怀疑。他也有一长串犯罪记录，包括非法性交和非法拘禁。自3月5日起，戴克斯因违反假释规定而被关押，他的假释官称他是对社会的威胁。众所周知，拉维克和戴克斯都经常与一群冰毒瘾君子混在一起，这些人通过盗窃邮件和伪造来维持他们的毒瘾。这就引发了一个问题：他们是否参与了拨打给富国银行的欺诈电话，以获取卡罗尔·桑德的银行卡和账户的使用权。
The half-brothers quickly became the likely suspects in the Yosemite site seer murders as it was thought that the crime was carried out by more than one perpetrator. In addition, the pair were familiar with the local area and Lawick regularly spent time at a home in Modesto, 10 blocks from where Carol's wallet insert was found. By early April, the grand jury began interviewing witnesses to build a compelling case against Michael Lawick and Eugene Dykes. By now, attention had fully shifted from the Cedar Lodge in El Portao to the Modesto neighbourhoods and trailer parks where the methamphetamine trade thrived. Special Agent James Maddock expressed confidence over the new direction the investigation was taking. After months of inactivity, progress was now being made. He told the press, It's remarkable when you look at it, all the pieces we've been able to fill in. Every day we get information that helps us refine our working theory. Eugene Dykes' girlfriend was among those interviewed. She said that she knew in her heart that her boyfriend was involved in the murders.
这两位同母异父兄弟迅速成为约塞米蒂观光客谋杀案的主要嫌疑人，因为人们认为这起罪行是由不止一名作案者实施的。此外，这两人对当地十分熟悉，拉维克经常在莫德斯托的一处住所消磨时间，该处住所距离发现卡罗尔钱包夹的地方有10个街区之远。到4月初，大陪审团开始讯问证人，以便针对迈克尔·拉维克和尤金·戴克斯建立一个令人信服的案件。此时，注意力已完全从埃尔波塔奥的雪松小屋转移到了冰毒交易盛行的莫德斯托社区和拖车公园。特别特工詹姆斯·马多克对调查正在采取的新方向表示有信心。经过几个月的停滞不前，现在取得了进展。他告诉记者：当你回顾它时，这是非常显著的，我们已经能够拼凑出所有的碎片。我们每天都在获得有助于完善我们工作理论的信息。尤金·戴克斯的女友也在受讯问的人员之列。她说她内心深处知道她的男友卷入了谋杀案。
She then recalled the day Dykes was arrested for violating parole. He had arrived at her house high on methamphetamine. After ordering her to close all the doors and windows, he handed her a knife and a gun and told her to hide them. The police arrived at the house to arrest Dykes and seized both weapons. They asked his girlfriend if she had ever seen Dykes with an axe or saw blades. She said no, but explained that he usually carried another blade in addition to the gun. Another associate of the suspects was 41-year-old methamphetamine dealer Larry Utley. In late May, he held a man captive at his home in Modesto. He planned to drug the man in order to steal his bank cards. Three days later, the man told Utley he needed fresh air. Utley obliged and the man took the opportunity to escape.
她接着回忆起戴克斯因违反假释被捕的那一天。他吸食了冰毒后来到她家。在命令她关好所有的门窗后，他递给她一把刀和一把枪，并告诉她把它们藏起来。警察来到家中逮捕了戴克斯并查获了两把武器。他们问他的女友是否曾见过戴克斯带着斧头或锯条。她说没有，但解释说除了枪之外，他通常还随身携带另一把刀。嫌疑人的另一名熟人是41岁的冰毒贩子拉里·乌特利。5月下旬，他在莫德斯托的家中将一名男子扣为人质。他计划给该男子下药以盗取他的银行卡。三天后，这名男子告诉乌特利他需要呼吸新鲜空气。乌特利同意了，该男子趁机逃跑。
Utley was arrested for kidnapping and criminal conspiracy. He underwent polygraph testing, during which he denied having anything to do with the Yosemite sightseer murders. Results revealed he was being truthful. Twelve days later, police arrested 24-year-old Modesto local Kenneth Stewart for stabbing and attempting to shoot an ex-con he had served time with. Stewart was a known associate of Eugene Dykes. Police hoped that arresting Stewart would pressure him into disclosing anything he might know about the Yosemite murders, but he remained tight-lipped. Yet another suspect on the FBI's radar was 46-year-old Tuolumne County man Paul Candler Jr. He owned a house in the Yosemite area that had burned down around the time Carol, Julie and Sylvina went missing.
乌特利因绑架和刑事共谋罪被捕。他接受了测谎仪测试，期间他否认自己与约塞米蒂观光客谋杀案有任何关系。结果显示他说的是实话。十二天后，警方逮捕了24岁的莫德斯托本地人肯尼斯·斯图尔特，罪名是刺伤并试图枪击一名他曾与之一起服刑的前罪犯。斯图尔特是尤金·戴克斯的熟人。警方希望逮捕斯图尔特能向他施压，让他吐露他可能知道的关于约塞米蒂谋杀案的任何事情，但他三缄其口。联邦调查局雷达上的另一个嫌疑人是46岁的图奥米内县男子小保罗·坎德勒。他在约塞米蒂地区拥有一栋房子，这栋房子在卡罗尔、朱莉和西尔维娜失踪前后被烧毁。
Candler had since fled to Alabama to evade authorities after threatening to kill his mother. The FBI went to extreme lengths to extradite him back to California to face questioning over the Yosemite sightseer murders. To the FBI, the investigation into Michael Lawick and Eugene Dykes had been a success. Special Agent Maddox stated that although they weren't close to announcing any arrests in relation to the SUND Peloso case, the FBI believed those responsible were in custody for unrelated crimes. They had yet to conclusively link any of the aforementioned suspects to the murders due to what Maddox described as a cranks the circle of dopers who can't remember what they did yesterday, much less weeks ago. Complicating matters was the lack of a motive or physical evidence.
坎德勒此后为了逃避当局而逃往阿拉巴马州，此前他曾威胁要杀死他的母亲。联邦调查局竭尽全力将他引渡回加利福尼亚，以接受关于约塞米蒂观光客谋杀案的讯问。对联邦调查局而言，对迈克尔·拉维克和尤金·戴克斯的调查取得了成功。特别特工马多克斯表示，尽管他们离宣布与桑德·帕洛索案相关的任何逮捕还很远，但联邦调查局相信肇事者因无关罪行而被关押。由于马多克斯所描述的一群记不清昨天甚至几周前做过什么事情的瘾君子圈子，他们尚未将上述任何嫌疑人与谋杀案确凿地联系起来。让情况更加复杂的是缺乏动机或物证。
With Yosemite's summer tourist season underway, an FBI spokesperson clarified that the public had no reasons to be concerned as, quote, this case is not a manhunt for serial killers still on the loose. In mid-June, Eugene Dykes made a confession to police. He revealed that he and his half-brother Michael Lawick had participated in the abduction and murder of Carol and Julie SUND and Sylvina Peloso. He said he hadn't killed them, but had been involved in giving away their personal belongings, including checks and jewelry. He had another associate discard Carol's wallet insert in Modesto. Dykes later changed this story. This time, he claimed he had cut Carol's throat with a knife at a remote mountain location. He also said he had helped dispose of the bodies.
随着约塞米蒂夏季旅游季的展开，联邦调查局的一位发言人澄清说，公众没有理由担心，因为，引述如下，此案并非对仍在逃的连环杀手的搜捕。6月中旬，尤金·戴克斯向警方作了供认。他透露，他和他的同母异父兄弟迈克尔·拉维克参与了绑架和谋杀卡罗尔、朱莉·桑德以及西尔维娜·帕洛索。他说他没有杀害她们，但曾参与分发她们的个人物品，包括支票和珠宝。他让另一名熟人在莫德斯托丢弃了卡罗尔的钱包夹。戴克斯随后改变了这一说法。这一次，他声称自己在一个偏远的山区地点用刀割开了卡罗尔的喉咙。他还说他曾协助处理尸体。
Dykes was strapped to a polygraph and asked if he had harmed Sylvina. He answered no. The test indicated he was being deceptive. An acquaintance of Dykes agreed to wear a covert listening device while speaking to a teenage girl Dykes had been sexually involved with. During the conversation, the teen said that Dykes had admitted to her that he and another man had slit the throats of three women. She also revealed that she had helped Dykes create a fake ID using Carol SUND's driver's license. It was a compelling conversation, but investigators were unable to find any evidence to support it. They did uncover a ring that Dykes claimed to have stolen from Julie SUND. It was shown to her sister Regina, who said she was 90% sure it was Julie's. The FBI felt the ring supported Dykes' confession.
戴克斯被绑在测谎仪上，并被问及他是否伤害了西尔维娜. 他回答没有。测试表明他在撒谎。戴克斯的一位熟人同意在与一名与戴克斯有性关系的十几岁女孩交谈时佩戴隐蔽的监听设备。在谈话中，这名少女说戴克斯曾向她承认，他和另一个男子割断了三个女人的喉咙。她还透露，她曾帮助戴克斯使用卡罗尔·桑德的驾驶证制作了一张假身份证。这是一次引人入胜的对话，但调查人员无法找到任何证据来支持它。他们确实发现了一枚戴克斯声称是从朱莉·桑德那里偷来的戒指。这枚戒指被拿给她的姐姐雷吉娜看，雷吉娜说她有90%的把握这就是朱莉的。联邦调查局觉得这枚戒指支持了戴克斯的供词。
They searched a jeep wagon ear that Dykes said he'd been driving at the time of the abductions. They also examined a corvette that belonged to his half-brother. Both vehicles contained dark pink fibers akin to those found on Julie's body. The same fibers were also found on one of Dykes' jackets. The evidence was beginning to stack up. However, Dykes kept changing his story. His statements were inconsistent and he was unwilling or unable to prove his involvement. An FBI agent said,
他们搜查了一辆戴克斯说在绑架时驾驶的吉普旅行车。他们还检查了属于他同母异父兄弟的一辆克尔维特跑车。两辆车里都含有类似于朱莉尸体上发现的深粉色纤维。在戴克斯的一件夹克上也发现了同样的纤维。证据开始堆积起来。然而，戴克斯不断改变他的说法。他的陈述前后矛盾，并且不愿或无法证明他参与其中。一名联邦调查局特工说，
These guys are pathologically incapable of telling a straight story. In Dykes' own warped mind, he's trying to shift the ultimate responsibility to someone else. Another agent said, Dykes is talking to get the onus off him and onto his brother. He's trying to confuse people, trying to save himself retribution in prison. From his jail cell, Dykes agreed to an interview with the Associated Press. He denied having anything to do with the murders, adding, If I was involved, it wasn't through my knowledge.
这些人有病态的无能力讲述一个直截了当的故事。在戴克斯自己扭曲的心态中，他试图将最终的责任推给别人。另一名特工说，戴克斯说话是为了把责任从自己身上转移到他兄弟身上。他试图混淆视听，试图在监狱中免受报复。从他的牢房里，戴克斯同意接受美联社的采访。他否认与谋杀案有任何关系，并补充说：如果我参与了，那也不是我知情的情况下。
By the five-month anniversary of the murders, no arrests had been made. 26-year-old Joey Armstrong worked as a naturalist for the Yosemite Institute, a not-for-profit organization that ran education programs through a partnership with the park. Her job was to teach children about the animals, plants, environment and ecosystem of Yosemite. Joey cared deeply for the environment. She was a vegetarian, who would inform her friends and family about how to recycle. One of her superiors said, Joey was one of the finest naturalists and science teachers I ever met.
到了谋杀案发生五个月纪念日时，还没有人被逮捕。26岁的乔伊·阿姆斯特朗在约塞米蒂研究所担任自然学家，这是一个非营利组织，通过与公园的合作开展教育项目。她的工作是向孩子们传授约塞米蒂的动物、植物、环境和生态系统知识。乔伊非常关心环境。她是一个素食主义者，会向她的朋友和家人宣传如何回收利用。她的一位上司说：乔伊是我见过的最优秀的自然学家和科学教师之一。
Joey had recently moved in with her boyfriend Michael and another co-worker to a cabin in Forresta. The remote, unincorporated community was on the western edge of Yosemite. Joey's cabin was surrounded by woods and meadows. She loved her home and lifestyle, telling a friend it was straight out of a dream. Although the recent murders had unnerved her, Joey told her mother that she felt safe knowing that the people responsible were in custody. In her diary, she wrote, The monsters are gone. In late July 1999, Joey was preparing to visit a friend in Sorcelito, a small seaside town 180 miles west of Yosemite.
乔伊最近和她的男友迈克尔以及另一位同事搬进了福雷斯特的一间小屋。这个偏远的非建制社区位于约塞米蒂的西部边缘。乔伊的小屋四周环绕着树林和草地。她热爱她的家和生活方式，曾对朋友说这简直就像是从梦中搬出来的一样。尽管最近的谋杀案让她感到不安，但乔伊告诉她的母亲，得知肇事者已被拘留，她感到很安全。她在日记中写道：怪物已经消失了。在1999年7月下旬，乔伊正准备去拜访索尔塞利托的一位朋友，这是一个位于约塞米蒂以西180英里的海滨小镇。
She had packed her car and was ready to leave by the afternoon of Thursday, July 22. At 3am the next morning, a call was placed to the Yosemite National Park authorities. Joey's friend had phoned in worried as Joey never showed up to their place as planned. Officials headed to Joey's cabin to conduct a welfare check. Music was playing inside, but nobody was home. Joey's bed was in disarray, a pair of sunglasses were broken on the floor, and a bright red rag appeared to be out of place. Her car was still parked outside, packed and ready for her trip to Sorcelito. Given it was dark outside, park officials waited until first to light to carry out a search of the immediate area.
她已经收拾好了车，准备在7月22日星期四下午出发。第二天凌晨3点，一个电话打到了约塞米蒂国家公园当局。乔伊的朋友打来电话表示担忧，因为乔伊没有像计划的那样出现在他们的住处。官员们前往乔伊的小屋进行安康检查。里面播放着音乐，但屋里空无一人。乔伊的床上凌乱不堪，一副太阳镜在地板上摔碎了，一块鲜红色的抹布显得格格不入。她的车仍然停在外面，行李打包好，准备去索尔塞利托旅行。鉴于外面一片漆黑，公园官员等到天亮才对周边地区进行搜查。
When the search commenced, hours passed without any discoveries. At 1pm, park rangers ventured to a stream just a few hundred yards from Joey's cabin. Among an area of trampled vegetation, they stumbled across the decapitated body of a young woman. To be continued next week. Thanks for watching! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
搜查开始后，数小时过去没有任何发现。下午1点，公园巡护员冒险前往距离乔伊的小屋仅几百码远的一条小溪。在踩踏过的植被区域中，他们偶然发现了一名年轻女性的无头尸体。下周继续。谢谢观看！本期节目尚无评论。点击转录文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。